[Music]
recognizing the tremendous growth
happening in Clark County Pope Francis
has elevated Las Vegas to the
Archdiocese now the appointment creates
the 34th archdiocese in the United
States eight news now reporter Joshua
peguero explains what this means to the
Catholic Community
after being established as the Diocese
of Las Vegas in 1995 who will now be
known as the Archdiocese of Las Vegas
and that's mostly due to a growth in
population and parishioners driven by
Hispanics and Filipinos we are getting
an influx our parishes are very active
two of our parishes now have 40
000 registered parishioners some nine
and ten masses our masses are oftentimes
standing room only Archbishop George
Thomas says the last time any Pope
elevated the diocese to an archdiocese
in the U.S was in 2004. what that means
is that the Diocese of Reno and Salt
Lake City will now fall under the
control of the Archdiocese of Las Vegas
auxiliary Bishop Gregory Gordon this uh
creation by Pope Francis is a reflection
of the tremendous growth in Las Vegas a
pure research survey done in 2021 shows
more Americans are choosing not to
identify as religious only 2 21 of
adults identify as Catholic Archbishop
Thomas says there was a strong faith
here despite Las Vegas's moniker as the
city of sin there's a very strong
faith-filled family-oriented community
and I honestly believe that it is in
direct reaction to the carnality and
secularity of the strip Archbishop
Thomas will travel to the Vatican to
meet with Pope Francis on June 29th
reporting near di in Las Vegas Boulevard
Joshua Piero 8 news now Joshua thanks on
October 2nd there will be a big ceremony
in Las Vegas when the ambassador of the
Holy See comes to visit no Pope has ever
visited Las Vegas however Pope Benedict
did visit Nevada before becoming the
pontiff